Welcome back to the show, Zainab Johnson!
Yeah!
(audience cheering)
You have a very thriving comedy career,
but you started out as a math teacher?
Yes.
How did that matriculate?
That doesn't add up.
Oh, yeah!
We like it, we like it!
We're gonna party when she does a pun, ready?
Uh!
You wanna chest bump too?
Drew?
Okay.
I really wanna bring the chest bump back.
I feel like it's a lost art.
But yeah, how did like A get to B?
Yeah, and equal C, right?
Yes!
It was the only thing, not the only thing,
but it was the thing that I was good at
and it was like solid.
Like they say that if you have a degree in like STEM,
like the math, science, then you'll always be good.
So I was studying math, 'cause I didn't know anything else
and I got a degree.
And then, my father passed away
and I felt like in that moment
time was like of the essence, you know?
Like I felt like when he passed away,
it was so sudden, I don't know,
I had the thought like, "Well, if tomorrow's my last day,
I don't wanna have any regrets."
And when I thought that I packed up my car,
drove 3,000 miles from New York to L.A.
and became a comedian.
(audience clapping)
That's so amazing.
Yeah.
You learned something, right?
When you go through that,
you learn just how short life is.
So if there's something you want,
you better start now trying to get it.
Yeah, and also, and I didn't know this,
this is something that happened later.
My mother told me when I started
like getting good at comedy, she was like,
"You know your father would be really proud of you."
And I was like, "You think so?"
And she was like, "Yeah, you know,
your father always wanted to be a comedian."
Oh, wow.
And I had no idea.
She was like, "Yeah, you didn't know?"
And I'm like, "No, I didn't know," you know?
And she was like, "Yeah."
And so when I first started comedy at first,
because Zainab is such a unique name,
and Johnson is just like everybody,
right?
Yeah.
I was gonna drop Johnson.
And then, once my mom was like,
"Well, you know your father always wanted
to be a standup comedian," I was like,
"I'm gonna keep Johnson as I perform."
And now I feel like, this is gonna sound so cheesy,
but now I feel like when people announce me,
it's like my father is doing what he wanted to do.
Come on.
That is so meaningful.
Seriously.
Really and truly.
And thank you for that wisdom
and life lesson.
Of course.
(upbeat music)